hey what's up Samuel leaves here and
I've run my youtube channel to help
people in property and I think it's
really important for me not just to give
you content that I think that you want
to hear and you need to know but also
give people opportunity to ask questions
every single week and we do that on a
Sunday at 7 p.m. so from the last Q&A
sessions we've had some interesting
questions we've got a guy called deed or
and he says hi Samuel can lease option
agreements be used to purchase a
property in Scotland so do lease option
the records Colin I've read it is
possible but also read that in most
cases that it is not thank you
so deed can lease options work in
Scotland's I've never done one my
understanding is that in Scotland the
rules around lease options are a little
different in Scotland they've got this
thing whereby that if you if you offered
to buy a property you have to buy it so
it's a bit like buying from auction with
lease options if you agree to buy a
property in five years time and so buy
now pay later you can do it the
difference in Scotland and this is my
understanding but I'd recommend speaking
to a solicitor in Scotland is that by
now pay later you have the obligation to
buy it later not the option whereas in
England if I say I'll buy the house for
a hundred grand in ten years
and then ten years later I'm thinking
actually I don't want it anymore you can
walk away from the property but they
have the obligation to sell it to you
whereas in Scotland you both have the
obligation so it's a little bit more
risky that's got a lot of this more like
delayed completion however most of my
lease option agreements all right in
Middlesbrough and stuff which is a four
hour drive from my house so if you're in
Scotland in fact Middlesbrough is
probably closer to Scotland than it is
to my house so what I would probably say
is if you want to do lease option
agreement as a strategy and you don't
like the idea of having the obligation
you want the option travel a few hours
south and and do it on the north of
England that would probably my advice
and another thing is this people always
love to try and find things that don't
work in their area to justify their lack
of action so like Oh Samuel you say HMOs
but in my area there's article four so I
can't you know they'd love to try and
find the reasons why something won't
work and like
work was what I'd say is potentially it
might be a mindset thinking might be a
case of look for things that do work
where you live as well rather than just
trying to find things that don't work so
that's my hamster my holistic answer a
most specific answer that I hope that's
helpful who acts iffy says Sam you or
how do you start building your network
of investors to pass on the packaged
deals my city doesn't have any property
events again it's a similar thing it's
like you know my city doesn't have
anything my area doesn't work
listen just generally speaking if you're
thinking your area doesn't work then
you've got two options number one is
find something that does work in your
area if there's no property events in
your area and you want there to be step
one up secondly is move area you have to
move house but there's a there's a the
the world is so small these days you
know we have planes and trains and cars
people are moaning that oh it doesn't
this doesn't work in what there's no
property there's yah you say there's no
property events in your area but I bet I
bet you if I was in your area I could
find a property networking event within
two-hour drive let's just we'll be so
also if you look into package of cell
deals sometimes you don't even want it
in your area because it's harder to sell
a package deal
to someone that's from the area
themselves because if they're from the
area themselves what happens is people
sometimes get a little bit like
skeptical they know all the streets and
they think the judge areas though well
that's the that's not the best side of
town though and they throw their brains
out and they bring their emotions in
when they know the area
did you go to a different area you can
just say look these are the facts and
figures on a piece of paper can be even
easier to sell package deals just people
outside of the town
so what I'm saying to you is find the
deals where you live sell them in a
different City just travel go keep on go
where the big networking events are go
where the people have got money and
they're looking to dump it into some of
the poor areas or some of the properties
where the prices are lower and that's
Jeremiah says I hope that helps and
gives you some kind of insight hi Samuel
if a potential buy to let property has
tenants and I buy the house can I keep
the current tenants or do they have to
be evicted
and then I have to source new ones thank
you sir great question great questions
so it depends is the answer all I like
buying houses with tenant said however
so you can buy properties and you can
keep the tenants you just need to tell
the solicitor when you buy the property
or if you want to keep the tennis or not
so buying tech pros and cons the pro of
buying and keeping the tenants is that
you don't have to find new tenants if
they've been in there for a long time
and they want to stay it's just a case
it's just really easy you stock and rent
immediately from day one so that that's
the pro and also you know exactly what
great is going to get because they're
already in this there's no guessing
that's the pro the con of buying
properties of tenants in is sometimes
they can be on contrary bad contracts so
make sure when you buy a property if
there's already tenants in there they're
on a propriety contract make sure that
they're paying rent make sure that good
tenants also if you're buying your
property and you're planning on turning
it into a HMO or you want to refurb in
out value or you want to do it as
serviced accommodation and if you're
wanting to do anything different with
the property then tenants are going to
be a pain and you want to buy the
property empty whereas if you're
literally just buying it to rent it out
and there's already tenants in there yes
you can keep them just make sure that
you check the contracts and make sure
that you are you know tell your
solicitors and what you want to do and
it can happen so hope that helps has
anyone got an idea how he that's me
Samuel how he makes money from the crash
courses because why would he do it for
free no hate just a question good
question what how do I keep doing stuff
for free you know what like these
YouTube videos I don't get paid to run
these YouTube videos I do I do add a
YouTube video for free I have full time
videographers that I have to pay then
put the content out there for free
I don't you get paid from YouTube
because I turn the ads off because I
don't want to get paid from YouTube
because I don't want there to being an
annoying ads that pop up everywhere my
crash course is free I have to pay for
the room higher but I do it for free my
books okay so they're not all free some
of them are on Amazon for like 10 10 15
pounds but I do give away a lot of free
books as well on my website I give
a lot of stuff for free what do I do
that many reasons number one is because
it's my mission and I'm a man I'm in a
fortunate situation whereby I don't have
to work I'll work because I want to so
everything that I do I'm doing from a
position of love and abundance and
mission so that's the first reason I
genuinely adore seeing people become
successful in property having people
every week on Windows on a Wednesday
share their story of financial freedom
as a result of my training and my
support that just that just gives me a
kick so other people's success is my
oxygen
number two selfish and speaking is I
believe in karma I believe that what
goes around comes around I believe in
the power of having a strong personal
brands because I put all these YouTube
videos out there constantly it what
happens is it means that all right for
instance when I would buy the castle and
I did it as a joint venture partner I
like to raise four hundred thousand
pounds like that I was able to do it
because people know who I am
people know me like me trust me because
of all the good free content that I put
out there so what goes around comes
around I really believe that you reap
what you sow so that's another reason
and then thirdly if I am I do run a
training business so we do have some of
our programmers are free some of our
programs are paid we have advanced
mental ships and so I am running a
training business which I get paid for
so people say if you're running a
training business it doesn't make sense
because what if you really six that's
been promised you why would you need to
train and the bottom line is is that's a
kind of a stupid question really because
if I said to Richard Branson hey why do
you have planes if your trains are so
successful he would just turn around and
say because I am an entrepreneur so I'm
an entrepreneur either lettings agency a
construction business development
investment training business so people
do pay me to train them but I believe
your good karma and that's what put out
so much good stuff for free it's my
mission and I love it so hope that
kannan hope that answers your question
cuz I get that a lot so anyway thank you
for those questions I hope the answers
were helpful if you want me to answer
your question then just put a comment
below with your questions I'll do my
best to try and answer as many as I can
and I'll afford to see you next Sunday
at 7 p.m. or do the same thing again see
soon peace out god bless you thanks
you